[Music]
ald
for
[Music]
alhamdulillah after praising Allah and
sending the salutations upon the
messenger
wasallam we thank all of the brothers
and sisters here
it's good to see you all may Allah T
bless you all in this life and the
next very important topic that we're
going to discuss tonight the topic of
Al and we're going to read from the work
of YF
Ali he died in the in the year um he was
born in 988 died in 1033 perhaps you've
seen some of his books in English he has
a book called that's been translated
called wonderings of the spirits and
souls and another book called the scales
of the day of judgment and the people on
the heights it's the same Sheik that
we're going to read from his works today
Abdul M references his book and the book
he wrote about the Mahi and Sh fan
references his book and his lecture
about the
Mahi we're going to cover the point
seven points tonight Point number one
the reality of the
Mah Point number two his name in
descriptions Point number three signs
before his appearance and the pledge
given to him Point number four is going
to be the 7year reign of the Mahi Point
number five is going to be the major
battle number six the M uniting
with and number seven the Christian
concept of the Mahi they believe in the
M also but it's different right so Point
number one the reality of the Mahi there
are numerous statements concerning the
mahi some people say that there is no
except for say he's the M some people
say was from what
generation the some people say he's the
M some people say there is no Mahi at
all the Sheik said but the correct point
is that the Mahi is a man that Allah T
will inspire during the last days and he
is not isaam he's a completely different
man
okay
so in his his book of History he
narrated a Hadith that has been narrated
from that the messenger of
Allah
said that only four men have ruled the
entire Earth at one time there's only
four men in the history of the world
that have been the king of the entire
world two of them are believers two and
two of them are
disbelievers as for the two believers
they
are
dor and
whoam that was the king of the entire
Earth as for the two disbelievers they
are nimod and
Ne and he said and the fifth one will be
the
M for my household the Mah for my
household all right now another
narration
from he said that the messenger of
Allah said this this he said that the um
will never be destroyed while I am at
the beginning of
it is at the end and the is in the
middle this had have been collected by
and
others it has been narrated
from that he said
to
now if you hear a statement or question
ask somebody if you know who answered
the question it means a little more
right
so he was from what generation from
right he was married to the daughter of
who huh Abu Hur right his father Al was
also from sahab and his father H was
also from the sahab his grandfather was
also from the sahab right n so he was
from the major early M of the some say
the most knowledgeable so said to
him is the m real is the m real he said
yes he is real he said so who is he from
he said he is from the
qur he asked him who from the qur he
said he's from Benny Hashim he said who
from Benny Hashim he said he's from the
children of ABD mutalib he he said what
children ofd mutalib he said from the
sons of FAA he said what son of f he
said that's enough right
now so the Mahi will be from the
children of Fatima now how many sons did
Fatima
have Hass and Hussein so now we need to
know which son is the Mah from the
lineage of hassin or Hussein which
one 50 chance get it right
brothers h
right this is based upon the statement
of the
messenger indeed this son of mine is a a
a leader a
master Allah will Rectify by way of him
two groups of Muslims so the
subtle um benefit of Hass having the
Mahi in his line
is because alass he gave up the he was
the leader but he gave it up to stop the
Muslims from fighting and because of
that Allah T is going to return it in
his lineage because whoever gives up
something for Allah Allah will give him
something better or he'll give something
better to their offspring so because he
gave up being Theif Allah is going to
bring the back from his offspring now
that's number
one going to number two his name and
description the messenger of
allaham
said he said if there was only one day
left in the
world Allah would lengthen that day
until he would send a man from my
household and this is
theah
his name will coincide it will be just
like my name and his father's name would
be like my father's name this Hadith has
been collected by Ahmed he said that if
there was only one day left in the D
Allah tal would make that day long
enough so he would send a man a man from
my household his name is going to be the
same as my name and his father's name is
going to be the same as my father's name
and another narration from the messenger
of
he said that a man will come from my um
his name will be the same as my
name and his etiquette his manners will
be like my manners so now we have two
things that have to coincide to find the
Mahi which are what have the same name
have the same what character okay he
said he will fill the Earth with Justice
as it had been filled with oppression so
here's the question Brothers the first
question what is the name of the
M
mdah
right he said the name of the is
muhammadd his is abdah so the doesn't
match but his name is Muhammad abdah
Alani may Allah mer upon him he said
there is great wisdom in US knowing the
name of the mahid and we're going to see
it's important to know how Jesus looked
how looks how the Mahi looks all these
things are important how do you know
they're important because the prophet
Alam told you how they look he don't
tell us anything that wasn't important
so because he told you that you know it
must be important and we're going to see
how important it is she albani says the
wisdom behind knowing the name of the m
is that Allah T knew there would be
numerous Liars claiming to be the
Mahi but their names wouldn't be
Muhammad and their father's name
wouldn't be
Abdullah see the people they come up and
they try to pretend to be the M but your
father didn't have the right name and
you don't have the right name he said an
example of this was gulam Ahmed who was
the founder of what deviant group
ahmedia right who died in the year
1908 she albani said the name gulam
means slave so he was named the slave of
Ahmed mean the slave of the messenger
his father's name was um um his father
also had a name Gul
more so said so Ahmed tried to get sliit
he tried to
drop gulam from his name to say well my
name is Ahmed so the Mahi now how would
this work if he said well my real my
real first name is Ahmed so I'm the M
how was he trying to make that
correlation
and a messenger come after him his name
shall be ahed hey that's me I'm ahed I'm
the
M GED was not the
M what did
match his name what
else his character his name his name is
his father and his character gam Ahmed
was a
c not only did he claim to be the
M he claimed something much greater he
said I saw in one of my contemplative
visions that I am Allah so I became
certain that I'm
him he didn't stop there G Ahmed said he
exalted me to Dignity of the Mahi and
the Messiah and opened up to me the
treasures of sacred wisdom so he claimed
to be Allah the Mah and the
Messiah but that's not it g he made a
claim I'm pretty confident in saying no
other man made this claim in the history
of the
world Allah knows
best he said verily Allah named me
medium he said I am the one who was
pregnant with
Jesus he said I am the one intended in
the verse in and the daughter of
IM the one who guarded her
Chastity and so we blew our soul he said
I'm
her he wrote to his successor and
companion nardine he said
since I was married I'm certain I'm not
a
man this is in his
writingi I read with my eyes in my
head he said surely the sword of Jesus
was blown into me like it was blown into
medium and I became pregnant
metaphorically and after some months
which did not which did not exceed 10 I
changed from medam and I became Isa and
that's how I became the son of
mediam so obviously he wasn't the Mahi
right who else claim to be the Mahi the
Nation of Islam they claimed that a man
named father Muhammad was the
Mahi
right Elijah Muhammad
he
said Allah whom we praise comes in the
person of Master father Muhammad the
great M expected by the Muslims so he
claimed that father Muhammad was Allah
and the
M father Muhammad was not the M what
didn't coincide
Yan his name or his character father
Muhammad was a cfir obviously right who
else to be the M what if the
Muhammad in a speech he gave March 13th
1993 he claimed to be the
Mahi worthy
Muhammad was not the
Mah what didn't
match his name didn't match nor did his
character what Muhammad was a he was not
the
Mahi that's coming later
inah the you thought they believe that a
man named Muhammad Al
massari who has been hiding in a cave
for 500 years was a m obviously it's not
true name didn't match character didn't
match
right so how do we know all these men
were not the
M he
said his name shall be like my name and
his character like my character now but
what happens when someone comes with the
same name has that happened it happened
a man named Muhammad abdah
he was the brother-in-law
of J he claimed to have a dream in which
he saw his brother-in-law was a
Mahi and then others some say hundreds
of people had the same dream that this
man is a
Mahi so on the morning of November 20th
1979 anyone know what happened they took
over the Kaa right this documented in
history they went and they took over the
ca 1979 November 20th one of the great
scholar Sheik
Muhammad Su was leading the feder prayer
that morning and they came in and this
was doing H season and so after the she
finished feder prayer they went to the
armed guards show their guns to take
over the Caba and what happens in Mecca
after every
prayer a janzer prayer the shake said
hold up they got their guns sh said hold
up we have to pray a janer prayer so
before you take over to cabba we got to
pray janaza prayer and so they let him
do it then after that they grab the
microphones and they locked the doors
and they took over the Caba now the
Sheikh was very smart right they said
anybody who's on Hajj you can go but if
you are from Saudi Arabia you are hes
you're going to stay here
so the sh he he was weing a gutra he
took it off put on a Kofi and walked
right out the
door and then he told the authorities
they took over the Caba right this is
has been narrated from his
sons all right so this thing started
November 20th it last until December
4th and
unfortunately um it was a lot of
Bloodshed the um man they thought was a
m Muhammad Abdullah he was killed
also his brother-in-law J man he was
captured along with others and they was
executed ALB was on that year he told
the story he said I was on Hajj and I
was in the tent of one of our Egyptian
brothers who lives in Saudi Arabia he
said his name was a Muhammad ABD
Al anybody heard him before who's his
brother Hass AB this is the old brother
Hass Allah have mercy on both of them so
the she he gives a nice story about him
and Muhammad and the she said so the
people began to say the Mahi has
appeared the Mahi has
appeared and the she albani he said how
do you know he's the Mahi and they said
because all these people had the same
dream and then they use the Hadith as
proof because this
man man was a student of knowledge he
wasn't like a he was a student of
knowledge so they said well the sahaba
all them had the same dream that Ram
that the night of power W the 27th night
and the prophet Alam he confirmed their
dream so therefore we all had the same
dream this man's a m it must be true
what do you think shab said to them
their proof is that all the sahaba when
they had the same dream it was true
therefore we have the same dream it must
be true what do you think shab Ben said
to
them you're not the
sahaba you're not the sahaba you're
wrong and this is why you have to return
the F back to the they knew this man
wasn't the m and obviously he wasn't the
M right now so his description how does
the M look the messenger of Allah s
wasallam he said the
M Min he is from my lineage he will have
a broad forehead and a prominent nose he
will fill the Earth with equity and
Justice like it was filled with
oppression and tyranny and he will rule
for 70 years years don't forget that
number 7 years this Hadith has been
narrated from the Sun
AB
so he will have a rise in the bridge of
his nose his nose will be long and thin
with a hump in the middle without it
being ugly without it being ugly as for
the meaning of a broad forehead it means
that his hair will be receding is a
broad forehead is when your hair starts
in the middle of your head IB a said he
will have thinning hair between the two
sides of his Temple and his hair will
have receded from his forehead to the
halfway point right now and some
narration mention that his he will die
at age 40 so he's a young man when when
when he appears he's just a man nothing
mystic not from the Angels not a prophet
he's a man but he's a great man that
Allah will inspire and we'll get to that
right but he's a young man when he comes
out okay that's number two number three
the signs before his appearance and the
pledge to him so from the signs of the
Mahi that will happen before he appears
is that the world will be filled with
Injustice there aith has been narrated
by pleas with him that the messenger of
Allah
said that the hour would not be
established
until until the Earth is filled with
what oppression and um hatred and
Injustice and then a man will come from
my household that will fill the world
with Justice and Equity like it was
filled with oppression this Hadith has
been collected by Ahmed and it has an
authentic chain of narration according
to the condition ofari Muslim the
messenger of Allah said at the end of
time my um will suffer a great Calamity
such that has never been heard of of
such that the Earth as vast as it may be
will become tight for them and the Earth
will be filled with oppression and
Injustice so that the believer will not
be able to find any Refuge from the
Injustice now listen to what Shin said
this had said that before the Mah comes
how is the world going to be Yan
Injustice
right they ask is it time for the M
yet his his answer was frightening
shamin died in 2001 roughly he said that
the Mah is not going to appear now
because there's still good in the world
there's still Brothers in America giv
da he said there's still Brothers in
America giving da so he's not coming now
cuz it's still good in the world he said
there still Brothers in America giving
da that means that when that time comes
Yan he it's not going to be happening he
said Allah protect
so this next Hadith
from albani found weakness in
it say it's authentic so we're going to
mention it who was the wife of the
messenger of
Allah she said that the prophet said
that they will be differing at the death
of a Khalifa and so a man will leave
from the people of Medina
fling to Mecca and the people of Mecca
will come to
him and they will bring him out while he
is hating it they will bring him out
while he is hating
it and they will make the pledge to him
between the r and the M it means that he
will the people of knowledge will
recognize him as the Mahi but he will
flee from being the Mah he will flee
from Medina and go to Mecca and they
will go inside his house and grab him
out of his
house and give him the pledge and say no
you're the Mahi and he's going to be
hating it now compare this to those
people that claim to be the
Mahi how you the Mahi and you waving a
flag saying you're the Mahi you begging
to be the Mahi the m is going to run
from it he's not going to want to be the
Mahi right as the prophet
saidd don't ask for leadership because
if you ask for it you're going to be
entrusted to it by yourself but if you
receive it without asking for it you're
going to be aided in it this how defense
collect Muslim so one of the major signs
Yan is
that when these Scholars go to get him
it's like they're going to know he's the
Mahi but the the people are are still
going to be doubtful until something
major happens right and it shows how bad
the world is going to be and this next
ntion is collecting M Muslim an army is
going to set out to attack the
Kaa all
right an arm a large army is going to
set out to attack the Caba and when they
are in a large field the middle of them
is going to be swallowed up by the
earth and the first of them will call
back to the last of them and then
they'll get swallowed up too when our
mother AA may Allah pleas her heard this
she said well how will the first of them
and the last of them he swallowed up
when they had people who were just there
for the the souk um for the
marketplace he said the first of them
and the last of them are going to be
swallowed up and they'll be raised
according to their
intention she with theine explained this
he said this is going to be a huge Army
so big that they're going to have a silk
with them a Marketplace people that are
just traveling with the Army just to
sell
merchandise and when they they get to
this open field and they're going to do
what to attack the Kaa right so we have
to understand Y is going to get tight
you know we can't lose our religion when
we see what happened to the Muslim in
Philistine
because life is going to get worse
that's a reality right but look what
Allah does when they are going there to
attack the
ca got
some a the Earth is going to swallow
them up the first of the and and the
last of them he said
[Music]
and we see how big the Army is going to
be because they're going to have a souk
with a a market with them selling stuff
and there people there who don't even
know they're going to attack the C but
they just trying to do business but they
get swallowed up too and all T is going
to raise them according to their
intention
okay pleases him he said when the Army
is swallowed up in the desert area this
is a sign that the Mah is going to
appear right meaning that when the
people see this they say oh now we know
that you're
the the messenger of
Allah he said that the m is from us from
my household Allah will Rectify him in
one night this Hadith has been narrated
by ahed Ma with the Hass narration what
does it mean Allah will Rectify him in
one night she AB explains he said
meaning that initially he will not be
mentally prepared to lead the
um he said and this is likely to happen
to many people when they see corruption
and evil they isolate thems right they
isolate themselves therefore Allah is
going to rectify him in one
night he said an example we can give
that's not completely comparable is that
the messenger of allaham before Islam he
would isolate himself from the pagans
right and just Worship in the cave until
the Angels Came to him with Revelation
he said likewise the m is going to
isolate himself from the people and L in
one night is going to rectify him to
make him suitable to become the leader
of the
umah he said but it doesn't mean that
he's going to be sinful and in one night
he's going to become righteous no he's
not somebody that's sinful nor does it
mean he's going to be ignorant and not
he's going to get knowledge it doesn't
mean that he's already somebody that has
knowledge and already somebody that's
righteous but he's going to be made
suitable to become the leader number
four the seveny year reign how long
seven years keep that number in your
head the messenger of Allah he said that
the Mah is from my lineage he has a
broad forehead a prominent nose and he
will fill the Earth with Justice and
Equity as it was filled with oppression
and tyranny and he will rule for for 7
years and likewise during that time that
he rules the world is good right he said
the prophet Alam he said that a man will
come from my household and he will work
by my Sunnah and Allah will send down
the Barakat from the heavens and he will
raise up the Bara from the earth and
fill the Earth with Justice as it was
filled with oppression and he will rule
for seven years and he will live in bdus
so the Mahi is going to live in the area
of philistine right he's not going to
live in Mecca Medina this is also
important also during his Reign he will
be very generous with his wealth as
comes in the narration that from your
rulers your Khalifa is one who will give
wealth without counting
it t he said that the Mah is generous
with his wealth hard upon the workers
and merciful with the
poor
in a narration from Ahmed the messenger
of Allah he said I give you glad tiing
of the m a man that shall be raised from
my nation when the people differ and he
will fill the Earth with Justice as it
was filled with oppression and the
inhabitants of the heavens will be
pleased with him and the inhabitants of
the Earth shall be pleased with him and
he shall give out wealth
equally now during the time of the Mahi
there's going to be a major peace treaty
between the Muslim Muslims and the
non-muslims major peace treaty right the
messenger Alam he said that you will
make a peace treaty with Rome meaning
the Christians right and you will fight
against a common enemy and you will be
victorious this Hadi is authentic so the
Muslims and Christians are going to join
forces and make a major peace treaty and
they're going to fight against a common
enemy right you imagine that the Muslims
and Christians they're going to join
together and fight against a common
enemy me
okay
but the Christians are saying the Mah is
the leader of the world do you think
they are happy with this they they made
a peace treaty they're fighting against
the common enemy but our Lord tells us
they'll never be pleased with us until
when till you turn back from your
religion right so after the Mahi appears
and Allah T gives him the authority in
the land and the join forces with the
Christians it's going to be some plot in
there all right so this narration has
been narrated in Muslim that the prophet
said at the end of time my um will
suffer a great Calamity that has never
been heard of such that the Earth as
vast for them will become tight for them
and then Allah will send forth a man
from my family that will fill the Earth
with fatness and Justice as it was
filled with oppression and Injustice and
the Earth will not keep any seeds except
that shall bring them forth and the
heaven shall not have any water except
that shall send it down abundant rain
and this will last for seven eight or 9
years and this time the dead will wish
that the living were alive so they could
tell them how good life is so the life
is good during the time of the Mah but
it's good for
who everybody's not happy with this
right now let's go to number five the
major
battle
some say this word is comes from which
means flesh because this battle is going
to be a lot of flesh is going to be
slaughtered this is considered to be the
biggest battle in the history of mankind
right the major battle right so in this
narration it says that the Romans will
enter a peace treaty with you and you
will fight a common enemy and you will
be Victorious and you will collect The
Spoils of War this is before the major
battle this is not the major battle
right then you will stop at a meow with
many Hill loocks and a man from the
christans will raise the cross and say
the cross has
prevailed now who fought this battle the
Muslims and the Christians were on the
same side right but when the Battle Is
Over the Christians going to say the the
cross won the
battle and a man from Muslim Muslim is
going to get angry and he's going to go
break the
cross and that's going to set it
everything off when he breaks the cross
the Christians are going to break the
peace
treaty this Hadith has been collected in
Ma and then they will gather for a
fierce
battle
now in Hadi collected in Muslim from Abu
Hur that the messenger of Allah sallam
he said that the hour will not begin
into the bantine mean the Christians
they camp
at right and this is a place near Syria
he said and the Army shall be composed
of the best of the people on the Earth
at that time and the best army from
Medina shall go out to meet them right
so you have the Christian army they
camping in Syria they broke the peace
treaty with the Muslims and now they're
ready to fight the Muslims and the
Muslims shall go out from Medina to meet
them and when they Reigns in the ranks
the Christians will say don't stand
between us and those who took prisons
from us now what does that mean so you
have the Muslim Army right and they
fought together with the Christians when
they were fighting together with the
Christians some Christians became
Muslim and they left Christianity and
they joined the Muslims okay we fighting
together but now got some da now I'm a
Muslim now so when the treaty is broken
the Christians are going to say okay
well give us those Christians back that
were in our army and we're going to
fight
them now they want to fight those new
Muslims they used to be with us they now
they with you now our peace treat is
gone move out the way and we're going to
fight them you guys are Arabs they're
not we want to fight them what do you
think the Muslim going to do
Noe the Muslim will say w we will never
let you reach our brothers and so
they're going to fight but onethird of
the Muslim Army is going to flee and it
said Allah would never forgive
them another third shall be killed and
they shall be the best of
Martyrs and onethird shall Prevail and
they will never succumb to any Fitness
after that day and they will conquer
Constantinople this battle is described
as the greatest battle in the history of
mankind there's a Hadith in sah Muslim
from abdah that describes this battle
you see how Fierce this battle is this
is the greatest imagine war war II
Vietnam this is the greatest battle ever
right it says the last hour will not
come until shares of inheritance are not
distributed and no one rejoices Over The
Spoils of
War right you imagine a war and no one
wants to spos of War said an enemy will
gather against the people of Islam this
is that major battle and the people of
Islam will gather against them and then
he motioned with his hand in the
direction of Syria and he said do you
mean the byzantines he said yes he said
during this fighting there will be a
great retreat mean there remance third
Army is going to leave said the Muslims
will send out a Detachment to fight to
the death don't come back until you're
Victorious and they will fight until the
Night Comes and both sides will go back
neither having won but the first
attachment is wiped out now the Muslims
have to send a whole new Detachment
fight to the death don't come back until
you wi the same thing Night Comes both
side goes back and nobody has one but
this Detachment is wiped out and then
the Muslim send another Detachment same
instruction what's the instruction
Victory or death right and when the
evening comes no one has prevailed on
the fourth day the Muslim will charge
the enemy and Allah will decree that the
enemy shall be routed and the Muslims
shall win said this shall be a battle
like no one has ever seen to the extent
that if a bird flies overhead it's going
to get shot down
dead so there will be a large scale
Massacre and when the body count is done
there will only be one man
out of a 100 relatives that's alive out
of all the relatives you only find one
out of 100 people that's related that's
alive so how can anybody Rejoice over
inheritance and spos a war when all the
family is dead who wants to get The
Spoils of War how can you enjoy that how
can you enjoy inheriting and all your
families
dead
so they're going to be in this state
just having got done with this major
battle and then they're going going to
hear about something worse than this
which is
what worse than that the worst thing
ever is going to be said at the has
appeared after all that he just got done
with the biggest battle in history is
going to say at theal has appeared and
he's with your Offspring he's he's with
your
family so they're going to leave and go
to see if this is true or not and the
brother our brother's going to discuss
at the job the prophet he said I know
their name Nam and the names of their
forefathers and the colors of their
horses there will be the best horsemen
on the surface of Earth that day mean
these people who win this
battle now we're going to skip to the
end of the story and and and then we'll
mention about something else number six
is the m and he will Unite with
Jesus okay so we know when at the Jou
appears he's going to be on the earth
for how
long 40 days days one the first day is
like a year second day is like a month
next day is like a week and the rest
days are like regular days right so at
the end of that when at the has his army
he's about to go he's ready to go attack
the Muslims
then descends down because he's still
alive he descends down on the wings of
two angels at what prayer feder prayer
and and the
say oh Spirit that's created by Allah
lead us in prayer and he will say no
this um you lead each other so he would
tell the Mah to go lead them in prayer
fan he says but you have to know that
the Mahi is only going to lead Issa in
prayer one
time after that Issa is going to lead
all the prayers all right so the Mah is
only going to lead for the F prayer but
after that is going to lead all the
other prayers cuz he he's going to be
the leader okay then the Mahi will you
know after the the
battle she fan says the the Mahi will
eventually die of natural cause and
he'll be buried in b m this and E medium
will lead the prayer over him now the
last thing is what number seven what's
that
about the Christian concept of the Mahi
do the Christians believe in the M they
do believe it or not so this major
battle this major battle the Christians
call this battle
what
Armageddon this is Armageddon of the
Christians now Armageddon means heill of
megiddo is based upon a place right
Armageddon is actually a place that's in
Philistine they call it Northern Israel
you know but it's actually a place and
they believe that this battle is going
to take place now
actually you know there's a church it's
called the Cornerstone Church in San
Antonio Texas they raised over $700
million to establish a Jewish state in
Israel because they believe in order for
Jesus to come back that the Jews have to
be there they say now when he comes back
he's going to kill two-thirds of y'all
but we want him to you guys there so he
can come back
okay now they have a lobbying
organization that they raise this money
with the the name of the organization is
called Christians United for Israel
what's the acronym what's the um what it
call that
thing what is it
kofy Christians United for Israel called
kufi
right play on words huh so they built
settlements in the Muslim area of
Palestine which is actually
against international law okay so the
Christians also believe in the
Antichrist right they they believe in
this what is the sign of the Antichrist
for the Christians the Christians
believe that when the Antichrist comes
he's going to be here for 7even years of
tribulation who they believe the
Antichrist
is they said the Antichrist is going to
be here for seven years of tribulation
that's going to start with a with him
bringing a peace treaty with Israel they
say the Antichrist is is is going to
bring peace to the world and for seven
years the Christians are going to be
tormented they believe that the Mah is
the Antichrist there's actually a man
named um Michael Yousef a Christian guy
in Atlanta Georgia who wrote a whole
book explaining how the Mahi is the
Antichrist
foolish okay so they believe that
according to the Christians that it's
going to be this great battle of
Armageddon and when the Christians are
and the Jews are about to lose the
battle Jesus is going to appear and
defeat the Antichrist now we know that
after this battle is over with who's
going to appear
at the job you see
now and they said and when Jesus comes
back he's going to convert people by
hundreds of the thousands and we know
that a lot of people are going to follow
him now I tell you something about me I
grew up in Raleigh North Carolina in the
United Church of Christ went to church
every Sunday from 9: in the morning to
3: in the afternoon was like a job 6
hours right and I remember something
vividly that was said by Reverend Donald
El
McCoy he said that when Jesus comes back
he's going to be real ugly so you have
to accept him for who he is not how he
looks W he said that going have one eye
you know when he was on a cross the The
Thorn poked out one of his
eyes who is he describing at the job
describe him to a te I was a young
Christian at the time I didn't okay he's
going to be
ugly you have to set him for he is we
know that is to May him is very handsome
right very handsome man doesn't look
anything like that but he he described
him to a te and that's the one thing you
know I you know I sat up when he said
that you know of course we couldn't
sleep in church you know you get beat
back in the day and that's important
because I always tell the young Muslim
kids you know the jumi is 15 or 20
minutes you better not fall asleep
because I sat in church six
hours and no cell phone could move right
listen to sh and kufer but he described
him to a te so the Christians believe
that the m is the Antichrist and the
Antichrist
is you see
so this is who they are expecting all
right now
so this is what I wanteded um um to
cover I hope it was clear to everyone
about the issue of the Mah this is a
very important issue and we know that y
things that going to be a time in life
that the world is is going to get
difficult but you just you you have to
hold on to your patience and seek Refuge
with
allaha